eric woerth il a
presque prête
elle descend l'escalier pour qu'elle
fasse gaffe à la dernière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis restée une brochette julia
roberts a fait moins chier way j'attends
que vous hein
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous le pensez
je vous demande de vous arrêter
franchement c'est la faute du taxi c'est
à dire ouais toi tu pourrais danser toi
même et non pas parce qu'on danse dans
cette émission mais on a arditi qui
s'est blessé au pied et on a des filles
qui s'est blessé on a les yeux blessés
le sujet ce qui c'est une connerie c'est
six mois ouais c'est vrai la raison
laurent tu devras comme les pantalons
rouges il faudrait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as vu le plateau la plateau il ya
toujours là sur quatre invités il ya
trois humoristes c'est vendredi tout est
permis
au juge je glisse un petit message parce
qu'on reconnaît vous les humoristes
voilà quand c'est pas vous qui fait des
blagues ça rigole jamais donc florence
vous avez fait des chroniques chez
ruquier qui amène dans le grand journal
guillermo sur france inter je vous
préviens si y'en a qui rigole pas géré
diffus sapir chronique
à on est sympa on fait des blagues
sharon est rigolo c'est les pires
thierry alors que au moins regarder avec
arditi on n'est pas déçu voilà ça c'est
le
plus important
[Musique]
lens lens foresti qui vient pour son
dernier film qui s'appelle deux plus
belles florence ou une femme qui sort
d'un cancer du sein et qui essaie de
retrouver une vie normale
pierre arditi re bonsoir
nom alors je préfère première c'est pas
une comédie et d'ailleurs je vous
préviens thierry il est hors de question
que j'entende une seule fois que deux
plus belles c'est le tchao pantin de
florence foresti away florence foresti
est une comédienne un point c'est tout
est ce que quand guillaume canet fait
rock'n'roll on lui dit c'est sont les
loups la cuisse je ne crois pas l'autre
et laissez la tranquille
[Applaudissements]
ça roule qui était formidable qu'un
roulement on peut lire un petit peu à
contre emploi parce qu'un rôle à contre
emploi il connaît un humoriste et qu'on
ordos un rôle grave mais un rôle à
contre emploi pour une opinion bas ce
serait de jouer une assistante
parlementaire
à côté de vous il ya mathieu kassovitz
qui est formidable aussi il serait très
bien il parle pas du 11 septembre il est
extraordinaire et non il n'ya pas
essayer de vous convaincre que les
illuminati avait créé le cancer pour
tuer le lobby des puissances financières
américaines ça sent le très beau succès
vraiment de toute façon si c'est pas le
cas kassovitz dira que c'était une
conspiration des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
en tout cas dans le film pour vous en
sortir il ya nicole garcia qui joue une
prof de danse et qui essaie de vous
apprendre à être une vraie femme au
mentor ouais ouais d'apprentissage
d'être une fin du vous a montré une
photo d'un mandat lire du coup
merci
conscient
cela je suis preneur
on passe maintenant à notre thé au top
du top de la semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut les terriens
autour du samedi soir bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
d'accord mais qui est en fait c'est pour
faire croire qu'il ya une ambiance de
fou sur le plateau
[Applaudissements]
la différence entre florence foresti et
thierry ardisson c'est que thierry
ardisson ne peut pas imiter florence
fort
à la relance on vous a connu
chroniqueuse chez stéphane bern puis
chez ruquier ensuite votre notoriété
exploser rapidement vous êtes imposé
comme l'humoriste préféré des français
avec des spectacles comme mad as fuck
her foresti partie madame foresti vous
avez rempli les plus grandes salles vous
avez explosé les audiences à la télé
vous avez vendu des tas de dvd j'ai même
présenté les césar
d
or le monde est aujourd'hui florence
[Musique]
on vous découvre pour la première fois
dans un registre dramatique
plus touchantes que jamais révélant une
nouvelle facette de votre personnalité
au cinéma dans le film deux plus belles
gt affiche de deux plus belles daniel
d'hab avec nicole garcia mathieu
kassovitz en salles le 8 mars et c'est
une comédie dramatique pas du tout comme
combine 3 cl comédie dramatique qui ne
veut strictement rien dire vous savez
quoi si t'as rien à dire
excuse mort drama drama essais d'action
donc ça veut dire c'est une comédie où
il ya de l'action ça veut absolument
rien dire c'est un film c'est d'avis
film voilà tiens c'est un film
alors c'est les chars de lui si qui
sortent du juge d'un cancer et qui va
réapprendre à vivre et à aimer et
surtout assez mais pour devenir la femme
qu'elle n'avait jamais réussi à être
avec vous il ya mathieu kassovitz qui
joue clovis un séducteur qui ne parvient
pas à vous séduire ce extraordinaire non
oui ça l'est mais le faible cours la
réponse est
oui je lui résiste alors ça m'énerve
mais même là dessus que se souvient
mathieu kassovitz elle à [__]
nicole garcia qui joue dalila votre
mentor et qu'il en eaux troubles mais du
lebret d'ordinaire elle vous êtes dans
la reconquête de votre immunité elle est
vraiment qu'on la voit dans des rôles
comme ça c'est alors c'est dingue ça
fait quinze ans que porter des perruques
pour faire marrer les gens et là d'un
seul coup c'est parce que vous êtes
guérir un cancer a été dû retrouver la
perruque d'ailleurs alors le personnage
a été écrit sur mesure pour vous par un
gaël un jour elle vous envoie un mail de
clavetage il ya quatre ans ouais et vous
lui répondez tout de suite quoi ah ouais
j'ai tout de suite été hyper touché par
son écriture donc
elle a développé le scénario dans la
foulée c'est difficile pour vous de
jouer un rôle comme ça j'imagine parce
que vous avez tendance à mal à vous
réfugier dans dans votre légendaire
autodérision j'imagine m'en sers
nettement
ouais mais bon c'était tout le défi
aussi c'était tout l'intérêt c'était que
je sorte un peu de ma zone de confort
comme on dit tous les humoristes rêve de
de faire pleurer à un moment ou à un
autre mais mais là je trouve que c'est
très très réussie et très juste en fait
à aucun moment on pense que vous êtes
une humoriste à temps mais là si les
gens rigolent saisira t as pas du tout
alors comme effectivement vous êtes
pudique la scène du baiser était très
très difficile oui ah bah évidemment me
bon caso il y dit cui dian son os x est
bien là
il détend à comme on dit il devait en
fait c'est pas du tout sur un film c'est
de rouler une pelle à kassovitz la
visite j'avais une folle envie de jouer
avec lui oui j'avais envie de jouer avec
lui mais comme j'ai envie de jouer avec
tant de comédiens évidemment là c'est
parce qu'il ressemblait ben oui pierre
évidemment mais pierre s'est livrée vite
[Applaudissements]
alors lui a déclaré je pensais que
c'était pour florence un plaisir quelque
chose de naturel mais tout ce qu'elle
fait douloureux qui cadix à lui que ce
ouais ça le fait marrer et kasso parce
que qu'est-ce au genre mon pote nom
mathieu kassovitz a là un écart matin
maths ça le fait marrer parce que bas
parce que oui je suis anxieuse et ou
alors bon il a lâché prise dans la vie
qui est admirable d'ailleurs une grande
liberté que je vais en vie mais vous
êtes hyper control freak et c'est pour
ça qu'on vous aime en fait quand on a
bossé ensemble sur le prime time sur
canal ces trois semaines pour faire une
séquence de merde belgique c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai un peu plus nul
que les autres lorsque l'on met pas du
tout en les critiques sont excellentes
le figaro a dit florence foresti et
bouleversante elle endosse de façon
convaincante un rôle à contre-emploi
évidemment et tous les journalistes je
sais parle de tchao pantin de galabru
dans le juge et l'assassin ou de bourvil
c'était un émoi en savons un
triomphalisme
et
[Applaudissements]
alors l'année dernière aux césars
zoologie michael douglas oui cet avis et
georges clou lycée c'est dommage cgt à
sanaa c'est assad georges c'est un peu
dommage pour les césars maintenant
voulait pu les présenter voulais gagner
il est présenté j'ai dit que je ne
ferais pas deux fois de suite mais
j'adore présenter ses offres c'est un
exercice que j'adore faire un show pour
la télé c'est c'est ce que je préfère
donc j'ai jamais dis je le referais pas
vous sentez actrice maintenant mais si
j'avais senti avec tracy donc vous
n'avez pas dire des trucs genre
l'ambiance sur le tournage était
extraordinaire vous prendrez autant de
plaisir à voir le film que que nous nous
en avons eu sur le tournage et ton vrai
rôle c'est ton rôle de maman dans la vie
il faut dire aussi j'espère que le film
rencontrera son public
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à sortir de
ce rôle ah oui j'étais habitent ici
alors là où j'ai vu que vous étiez
devenu une vraie actrice et tout à
l'heure dans la neige quel effet vais
demander de l'eau d'evian pour laver
votre chien
c'est normal vous lutter contre la
pollution de l'eau trouble sauver la
planète
c'est mélanie laurent c'est plus du tout
arrangement alors je vous connais si
vous êtes très discrète sur votre sur
votre vie privée mais là c'est trop là
un bon titre on veut savoir la non non
non je te dis ça va toujours très bien
et xavier non non oui dites moi oui ça
va très bien et au niveau du fis donc
c'est vrai qu'il
me réponde mêmes
ouais
c'est ma journée j'ai bien fait de venir
un tas vue non mais t'es vachement bien
au final j'en sais rien non mais je veux
dire et maintenant en hommage à mathieu
kassovitz nous allons faire une
interview la haine
[Musique]
foresti qu'est ce que vous détestez
qu'on dise de vous dans les journaux
qu'est ce que t'es bon je déteste qu'on
dise que j'ai la grosse tête alors qu'il
n'ya pas plus cool que moi c'est vrai
bon jeu par l'ars luttes internes aux
gens quoi
qu'est ce que vous détestez dans le
sport a batu gérard 10 sport ouais il
faut se laver les cheveux après on perd
un temps fou c'est important
qu'est ce que vous détestez manger
et pas je ne sais pas parce que je le
mange pas qu'est ce que vous détestez
dans le sexe
mais il faut cesser le feu après
[Applaudissements]
ça dépend qui vous tirent les cheveux il
ya des victoires il ya des mecs qui ont
les mains propres et je ne parle pas de
ça me dites pas que je vais pas vous
faire tirer les cheveux bon allez
ensuite
alors que zain allusion sur les jacks
faciale
c'est les dupont et pondu de l'interview
les de la chose ou deux mamans on s'est
retrouvés et on s'aime et on s'occupe
comme entrant les jours
comme toi
nos bêta
voilà ça fait ça
j'ai pas d'amis comme lui la teigne
petite réflexion bien c'est une émission
de [__]
homophobes
les actrices
mais qu'est ce que je fous là pts tu
viens parce que tu nous es bête et je
viens parce que j'aime foresti est
ce que vous détestez en mettant une
fille
moi j'aime à peu près tout dans le fait
d'être anxieux sauf à l'injonction avec
gens qui en plus de la jonction avec
joly il faut être gentil non ça ce n'est
forcément une
[__] hystérique donc c'est compliqué on
n'a pas le droit entre les deux est ce
que vous détestez à la téloche bas pour
se laver les cheveux après
qu'est ce que vous détestez en politique
qu'est ce que je déteste en politique
yat il encore quelque chose qu'on aime
en politique non
est ce que vous détestez qu'on utilise
pour vous abordez pourquoi tu étais pas
laver les cheveux
j'aime pas qu'on me disait vous
ressemblez à l'humoriste alors déjà je
lui ressemble pas que je suis et ans du
lion dit l'humoriste
j'en veux plus les humoristes qu'est ce
que le diester comme bout comme olé olé
mois en verlan sam bel air je supporte
plus
non pour de vrai je supporte plus le
verlan chelou rôle ou parce que les
enfants voient comme ça maintenant ma
fille et elle sait pas que celle où ça
veut dire louche le gym effet le verlan
de celle où tout se rapprocher dis nous
ce qu'est ce que vous détestez dans la
vie en général la fin je trouve c'est
une très mauvaise idée ce dénouement
avec son frère est ce que vous détestez
sur ce plateau là maintenant tu as clim
depuis toujours la fois
l'armée sahraouie tête s'était améliorée
xv alors qu'est ce que vous détestez en
vous
en vous en moi j'avoue mon nez pourquoi
vous ne changez pas parce que je suis
douillette j'ai refait la cloison déjà
et ça m'a fait super mal et on est tous
avec toi comme papier peint
j'ai laissé les murs bruts et à le
médecin m'a dit si vous faites
l'esthétique ça sera de 30 fois plus
douloureuse allez tant pis pour moi je
reste avec le shabbat une ruche tout au
plus tard
qu'est ce que vous détestez chez moi
influences
soul man ray un tir il vous est
absolument parfait il a mangé
ac il ya peut-être des trucs abominable
chez lui mais je le connais pas vous
ètes lamentable pour rejoindre pierre
voilà
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu